puede que las cifras hayan disminuido
sin embargo aún hay un flujo constante
de pacientes de kobe que son admitidos
en cuidados intensivos en francia en
este hospital al norte de marsella y
siete pacientes uno de ellos solo tiene
27 años tras meses de luchar contra el
virus el personal médico ha adaptado el
modo en que trata a estos enfermos una
mujer de 81 años fue admitida algunos
días pero no está usando un ventilador
en lugar de ello está recibiendo terapia
de oxígeno con una máscara
no nos permite alcanzar altos niveles
para que la paciente tenga suficiente
oxígeno mientras las cicatrices en el
pulmón sana nos evita poner al paciente
bajo anestesia general o un ventilador
que es muy invasivo y puede llevar a
complicaciones
este tratamiento no se usaba hace unos
meses porque los médicos pensaban que
podía contribuir a la expansión del
virus pero descubrieron que esto no
ocurre otras opciones nuevas incluyen
recetar anticoagulantes fármacos que
hacen la sangre más líquida para
prevenir coágulos también dexametazona
un esteroide usado por sus propiedades
anti-inflamatorias que ha reducido las
tasas de mortalidad en un tercio entre
pacientes con ventiladores en marzo de
abril la tasa de mortalidad de pacientes
con kobe en cuidados intensivos en
francia estaba entre el 35 y el 40 por
ciento ahora ha disminuido a entre el 25
y el 30 por ciento el virus aún puede
ser fatal pero la combinación de estos
nuevos tratamientos está aumentando las
posibilidades de que los pacientes
sobrevivan